[Music]
hello hi welcome to julia account 2022
workshop on the introduction of graph
computing we're excited to join you here
on this exciting topic
um my name is yanung li i'm the cto and
the co-founder of julius technologies
in the past
15 years also i have been spending a lot
of time building the most complex models
and analytical systems for big banks
have accumulated a lot of experience on
how to build these enterprise complex
systems
so today we're going to cover
uh why graph computing is such a great
solution for enterprise computing and
we're going to use a lot of
concrete examples to illustrate
illustrate the the key concept and
benefits
so here i'm going to
share my screen
um
so yeah if you can see the screen
if you can type in a chat room let me
know it's it's visible
okay
so
today's workshop
uh this is the agenda for the today's
workshop
uh first i'm going to make a short uh
presentation
covering the basic concepts and
and the key benefits of graph computing
and why it's important then we're going
to go through a benchmark study showing
the
some of the common platforms available
to uh to julia and python developers and
do a benchmark study of these different
platforms
then we're going to
use some of the real world examples to
illustrate how to build
complicated
large-scale and realistic graph
computing solution using julia's
platform
so
at this part of the prediction my
colleagues
from julius technology will be joining
me
so
first uh what is the graph computing
graph computing actually is a part of
this broader uh field called graph
technologies
uh graph technology has recently been
trending
uh attracted a lot of attentions gartner
forecasts that 80 percent of data and
analytics innovations will be made using
graph technologies
by 2025 up from 10
uh from 2021 so this is a huge forecast
of growth and a huge vote of confidence
by garner
so there are several different
categories of graph technologies so for
example uh people are most familiar with
are graph databases and such as
knowledge graphs so for example if you
look at the social network the data can
be organized as a complicated graph
so the second category is graph
analytics
or graph
ml so this is really about
how to write algorithm to analyze the
graph
for example find the shortest paths
try to find ways to dissect the graph
and
and also try to find see if
graphs are connected nodes are connected
to each other however these are not the
uh the the key
the focus of today's workshop today's
workshop is about the graph computing
which is
about how to build the systems and the
applications at graphs so the uh
platform that in this space include the
task airflow pytorch tensorflow
dagger.jl and of course julius
so these software provide
ways to build the complicated systems
and applications as a graph so first
question you may ask is why do we want
to do that why do we want to build a
system as a graph
so this goes back to the the the point
we mentioned earlier
uh about enterprise uh beauty enterprise
systems in particular enterprise data
and analytics
so for people who have worked on
enterprise software
you can appreciate that the enterprise
software is a totally different animal
from your desktop application or mobile
application
or even web application
because they tend to be like a
complex very opaque heavy
and also these systems tend to run for a
long time many of them run for decades
they accumulate tons of
technical debt and entropy over time
become they tend to become over overly
complicated bloated difficult to support
the army of developer to
to to to to to maintain and and
keep it up to date
so if you look at the why the enterprise
uh
system is is so
so difficult so so so expensive
of course
a part of the reason is the organization
itself like that
certainly bring a lot of complexity to
the to the systems
but if you focus on the technical
technology side
uh i summarize these six different
challenges purely from technology point
of view we call it the
we call uh scalability we call we have
acronym for them called stella
they particularly uh named
particularly our scalability
transparency explainability lineage
adaptability and reproducibility so of
course these six are not exhausted
exhaustive lists and many more
challenges but we think these six are
really the key difficult challenges to
solve in enterprise
enterprise computing world
and
that
if you look at these six different
challenges so one of them is now either
to solve all six of them together is a
very tall order so the reason why a
current enterprise system becomes so
bloated and difficult complex a big part
of that is the current development
environment or platform doesn't supply
general solution to the stellar
challenge so therefore it leaves the the
task to individual companies to have to
build this solution on their own so
these ad hoc solutions tend to be
inadequate
probably not
consistent
and also not optimal so as a result the
system becomes more and more complex
when you add more and more of these
requirements and features
so
how graph computing can help
so this slide shows a very high level
summary of
the the key difference between the
traditional program paradigm and the
graph computing paradigm so in the
traditional program paradigm we write a
lot of code
as
functions
basically the you look at any
programming language it eventually comes
down to collection functions
these functions can be compiled into
binary code then they'll be executed by
a runtime so the runtime can be
a single process or multiple process
running on cloud
it doesn't matter uh the key point here
that the wrong time
after executing your code give you the
results magically hopefully it's the
correct results
but however the the runtime tends to be
a big black box it doesn't give you any
insight on how the results were produced
it doesn't give you the intermediate
results it doesn't give you visibility
to any of these
uh any of these like input output
throughout the entire logic so if you
want to track or log some of these
intermediate results the programmer has
to make a effort either to log in
somewhere a file database or attach a
debugger to see the intermediate results
very difficult
to
to understand the system and also make
changes so in comparison graph computing
works
uh in a different way so it starts with
some kind of graph programming
uh
format or syntax so for example some
graph programming solution use the drag
and drop gui
to create these graphs
um
most of them follow certain api to
create graphs
so once we have the graph programming
that defines the
uh the logic
we don't execute the uh the code
directly instead we create a
intermediate representation called the
computation dag which is a directed
acyclic graph so this tag basically
capture all the logic flow of your your
your application or your system then
this computational dag will be
executed to give you the final results
so the key difference is that we have
this intermediate representation called
computational dac this is tremendously
useful
and it actually
later on in the next few pages we're
going to show how to solve the stellar
challenges we list in the beginning
so in this slide is a quick
quick explanation of what tag is
computational targets so we have a piece
of regular code
and on the right hand side you have the
corresponding tag representation
so the computational dag
is basically
a graph
with directed edges but without any
circles
so basically any program or systems
logic
reduced to a dag representation so the
dag is a very generic representation
regardless of how complex or or simple
your competition or system is it already
conceptually reduced to a tag
representation so for example
if you look at a single excel formula
uh
on a few excel formula connect data on a
spreadsheet
that is nothing but a dac also when you
see
the this complicated it system diagram
you notice these complicated arrows and
boxes that is nothing but the dag as
well so therefore like regardless of
complexity they all reduce to the dag
another point is also extremely
important that it's acyclic so when the
tag is acyclic it's guaranteed that when
we execute this tag every node is only
hit once because there can can be no
circles so therefore
this is a very useful property compared
to the traditional programming language
in functions which is a are permeated
with loops if conditions that make it
much easier to enforce runtime behavior
because we have a loop you may loop in
over a variable that
that determines your number of iteration
so just before the execution function
you have no way of knowing how many
iterations that func that loop will will
thread over
but with the dag if you iterate a number
of loops it will create like n sub
graphs from the graph topology you can
easily see and estimate the
computational resource and and the cost
of that computation make it much much
easier for the machine to optimize and
analyze and distribute automatically so
this is really the the key benefit of
having a computational graph
um so
this page really answers the the
previous question like a y graph is a
such a great solution and generic
solution
to to the stellar challenges we
mentioned earlier
so first the tag is a
generic reputation any computation
reduce the dag secondly we already
mentioned that for for example the tag
is great for uh for distribution
scalability because you just need to
write one distrib distribution algorithm
that works on an index then you have
solved all the distribution problem for
all the system that can be mapped to a
dag which pretty much covers everything
and also the other challenges
transparency explainability and lineage
all of them come for free within a dac
because the dag has the full information
about how the data flow from one node to
another how the computation logic works
on individual nodes and how the final
results is computed
so the last adaptability and
reproducibility these are much more a
bit more challenging than the the
previous challenges uh because um
for example first let me explain what
they mean
so for that adaptability means that when
you have a complex system it should be
easy to make changes
so it shouldn't take a lot of effort
write a lot of code to make changes to
your to your systems
um reproducibility means that you should
be easily created copies of your system
and
to use those copy to do experimentation
and around different scenarios so in
practice it sounds easy but in the
enterprise
setting it's incredibly hard because
for for for a complex organization
oftentimes they have one gigantic
production system that is so complex
costly or they're too expensive to
support to make identical copies of that
system most of the time is out of the
question for most organizations
and to make changes for complex system
actually you need to touch many
components of the system for potential
running on thousands of computers it's a
very difficult job to to coordinate and
plan that change oftentimes even
singular simple changes can take months
or years to implement
so just having a graph uh
solution is not going to be adequate to
solve the adaptability and
reproducibility problem so what we need
here really a local way to define your
your graph logic
so if we have a way to create a graph
solution that is also low code then we
can easily
take this local representation of your
production system and recreate recreate
it anywhere or we can take this local
recognition make modification to this
using this local representation and
regenerate the system with the new
functions and features so therefore the
key point here that
in order for the graph solution to
really completely solve
for the stellar
uh challenge
we need to make the low code so we have
to add the l to the acronym uh to
complete the
the stellar world
one of the l is for lineage another is
for low code so this is really the key
message you want to want to
share
in in the first part of the presentation
um so this slide
highlights what julius technology does
so i promise this is only slides with a
bit of
information about us so julius offer a
auto scaling low code
visual graph computing solution for
building transparent and adaptable data
and analytical pipelines
so julius is a generic stellar
platform for building enterprise systems
it allows enterprise to build the
stellar system at a fraction of time and
cost
so i see in the comments uh there are
some um
comments about the examples
so we're going to have plenty of
examples in the uh in the in the rest of
the workshop you'll see how it works
in practice
so so basically
here what we provide is a generic
development platform that already have
the stellar challenges solved to allow
developers to focus their energy
building the business use case and for
julia developer this means that we
provide
great tools for juliet developers to
tackle complex enterprise
problems where we see julia can have a
tremendous opportunity and
and the need in that space
so
now let's move on to explain a bit
better on this local graph programming
point
so of course graph computing starts with
a some kind of graph programming method
um so how you
do your graph program actually have
tremendous importance
uh in the
in the uh
in the performance
and characteristic of your your graph
computing solution so for example uh
here we can quickly
uh
say that any
gui based
solution drag and drop solution is not
going to scale because you cannot drag
and drop thousands of nodes and create a
graph from that so it has to be some
kind of programming
approach for the graph programming
graph solution
graph computing solution to work for
enterprise settings
so
in this case
the
here we are showing like how the typical
way of
creating
graphs like a typical graph
programming approach and also the
julia's local declarative
programming approach
so
in the
conventional
approach uh how we create
graph for example this is the approach
that uh followed by like a tensorflow
like airflow all of the the typical um
current
graph computing platform is you write in
traditional programming languages most
likely python
with some special api most likely python
decorators and once
python code is executed with a special
api instead of computing
the
numbers uh
it it actually recorded the logic of
that competition in the graph do a lot
of housekeeping and keep track of the
information the graph so that can be
executed later on as a dac so this is a
typical recording approach
um so the julius
local
like graph program approach actually
is based on a dsl domain specific
language called root dsl it's a very
simple declarative
syntax only with a
with minimum features it's especially
designed for graph creation
um so
because
when you do the standard recruiting
approach you have to like run the entire
program from beginning to end to
generate the graph in comparison
when we generate graph from root dsl
that happen directly it doesn't have any
intermediate we don't have to run the
program from beginning to end to to
create a graph so therefore
the the graph creation using root dsl is
orders of magnitude faster and much more
memory efficient
so let's like probably dig into a bit
more detail in this point which is the
important point i want to explain
clearly
um so when you write
uh graph
graph logic in the conventional
programming language using like a
typical recording approach
you wrote
you're basically writing with the full
general purpose programming language
features such as like types classes
functions loops
and and branches polymorphism all of
that are at your disposal so this is a
very complex set of language features
but if you look at the final output you
want to
produce
it's a computational dag which doesn't
have any of these features it didn't
have loops they didn't have
branches it didn't have polymorphism
it's just a competition tag which pretty
much like
with all of this information removed
so if you look at the traditional
approach
so in this case you write a lot of code
and then
just
make a lot of effort to write the graph
logic in using the traditional
programming languages
that only
have to have them
like on down the effect on down removed
in order to create a computational graph
because you have to run the entire
program to recording record them
and also you have to unroll the loops
like how to resolve the branches you
have to remove the map out of the
polymorphism so this seems to be a lot
more wasted effort so the reason
you're doing like unnecessary work on
each of this step so the reason that
you're not creating a graph using the
the right tools
you are using something that is not
designed for graph creation
so in comparison using the root dsl we
have a
local syntax that directly map to the
graph topology it just defines nodes and
dependencies
uh it doesn't support many of the
complex language features like functions
loops if statement whatever but it does
support polymorphism because that is we
do want to build different pipes
according to the different data types
that dynamic
behavior is important so therefore
it's much simpler set of
features in the root dso and it make it
much much easier to create a graph
because pretty much this root dsl can be
directly mapped and expanded to graph
without much
additional process compared to the
recording you have to do a lot of work
to unroll your
unravel your traditional program
language into into graphs
so this is also a i want to make another
point which is
if you look at the stellar challenge we
want to solve this stellar challenge
end-to-end
so once you have the computational graph
some of these challenges can be solved
for example distribution can be
automatic
but if you look at end to end this part
if you this part cannot scale and cannot
be easily distributed you haven't solved
the
stellar problem n20 yet so this is one
of the issues with the traditional
graph programming approach for example
if you create a very large graph that
can have hundreds of millions of node
when the graph become very large the
bookkeeping information also grows
the recording that graph can be much
much more expensive than like executing
that graph for for very large graphs so
in this case for the graph to scale to
the enterprise level
you have to solve the the the
parallelization and also the same
stellar challenge for this graph
creation part
so this is another point i want to make
so therefore rely upon the traditional
recording project we only solve
half of the the the problem like this
part still still remain challenging like
unresolved in comparison go with root
dsl we solve the entire
entire
end to end like from the graph creation
to the graph
distribution and
execution
so
now um
let's quickly back it up uh the claim
back up the claim by sharing some of the
benchmark studies
uh so here
this is a a comparison between
a julius
graph engine and a few
very like widely available graph
computing solutions
we did a benchmark that using a a single
example which are going to show a bit
more detail later but here the point is
that when the graph size increase
some of the many of these
alternative graph computing platform
cannot handle the the large graphs
so
none of them actually managed to finish
the execution of half million graph
within reasonable amount of time i
waited six hours couldn't
finish i have to stop but for julius its
orders are magnitude faster in terms of
graph creation and execution only take
15 seconds so that's actually not the
table
15 seconds to execute create and execute
the graph of size half a million which
is many orders of magnitude faster than
the rest of the uh the comparison
alternative
uh platforms
so
at this point you may think that
yes it it sounds interesting but doesn't
mean that
in order to use your graph computing
solution i have to code
everything i have using your root dsl
that is typically not the option at all
because you you may have complete
library that already
have i already have like been battle
tested for four years it's just too
valuable to to throw that investment
away
so
um
so i i think the the key point here is
that
you don't have to
like
you don't have to
uh record everything you have using the
root diasol so what we provide is a item
very simple item interface we're going
to show later on in the
in the examples that uh give the very
simple
interface to interact and interrupt with
the traditional program languages for
example when you have julia cc plus
python dot net java like the typical
mainstream program programming language
you can pretty much like plug in your
libraries into this atom interface so
difference between the root dsl and
atomy that the root dsl
governs the creation of the entire graph
pipeline
but in terms of what's happening at
individual node
that is determined by the individual
atom so basically every rule in the root
dsl refer to atom that basically specify
what logic to apply in individual nodes
so in this case the atom is named
obviously after atomic
meaning that
it only affects one particular node it
doesn't doesn't affect any other and
another node in the graph
so once we have these two
constructs defined then julius graph
engine will take them and automatically
generate during the entire system
according to the logic graph programming
in roon dsl and also the atom
uh atom adam
functions or atom
object to defined uh interfacing with
traditional programming function style
program
uh so this is a make this actually makes
the entire system building
uh
like a uh much much easier because the
system is created the entire pipeline is
created for you you don't have to write
a lot of imperative code to create the
the system
um
so
right so so i think this is a quick
conclusion of this part of the
presentation so the local graph
programming if you take away one point
at this point
it's really critical ingredient for
graph computing to realize its full
potential
by adding this low code
uh feature into graph programming we
actually offers a generic solution to
the stellar challenge in building
enterprise systems
um so at this point i'm going to
quickly walk through a bit more detail
of this benchmark
and then later on we're going to go
through some
detailed tutorials to show the
the root dsl syntax and the item
interface
so this benchmark
study
actually
is quite straightforward
so basically
use a very simple fibonacci
sequence type of calculation
and uh
and also we
we
we computed the summation of all the
even terms
of the fibonacci sequence
uh so in this case to make it more
interesting instead of running on scalar
we run on them on a vector of length 10.
so as you can see when you increase the
terms here you get a like a y which is a
very narrow but a deep graph
but as the summation of of the even
terms is a very like both deep and wide
dag so of course the the deep and white
diag is more challenging to to execute
to to to orchestrate
so then we use different uh
graph computing solution to solve these
two uh problem identical problems and uh
look at their look at their timing so
the timing we already reported
it's a dramatic uh
improvement uh to have the rudy cell so
here we're just going to quickly look at
the code
so this is a task implementation so
basically dusk as you can see use these
decorators
so to decorate the python function so
with the these decorators uh
when the dash runs
it doesn't create the results right away
instead of it added information to the
graph data structure
and all the host keeping information so
that it can be run in a distributed
manner later on so very similar diagram
has a very similar
approach like
we
have this spawn
macro
that specifies the task will be
recorded on the graph and around later
on
and also the tensorflow inflation is
similar but it has a
a decorator like this
so the last
we're going to cover the
julius implantation in more detail
in our first example but before we do
that let's just quickly show how to
sign up for
the
how to sign up for the
uh julius
free developer
website so basically all the examples we
are showing today are available through
our
free developer website
and you can
you can like
anyone with a google
email can login
and
and get
access to our web page for free and have
you can play with our tutorial examples
that we're showing today
at your leisure so here we just need to
click this sign up link
so i'm going to
share this
uh
now you just click through
and you can go to the
the the uh go to our web environment so
here you can see that we have the
entire example available so we're going
to go through next we're going to go
through this quick start
uh
example
uh as a first
tutorial
uh of the graph computing but let me
also
share the
curious graph this sign-up link as a
banner
yeah i i shared the
uh
sign up link in the in the chat
so now maybe it's a good time to
see if you have any questions like let's
let's
probably yeah let's probably take a
pause and
and look if we have
uh have some questions
so to ask questions please use the
pigeonhole
link
which
should already
be on the on the links so
yeah for some reason we only see the
github page
we can see
while you are
logging into julius web server
oh sorry like
what do you see
just the github page uh we can't see the
judy's graph
oh okay okay so do you see it now
yeah we it's like we see just the only
github page maybe you can
stop sharing and start sharing okay okay
so let me try that
yeah
okay
yeah that's that's great so
okay
right so i i think now let's probably
see if we have any questions from the
audience
to ask questions please use the the
pigeonhole link
okay i see some questions or they've
been answered uh
yeah there's a question about how a
relatively small research project
benefit from graph computing or is it an
overkill so it's hard to say
in general
but i think the
it's true that
the bigger
systems and bigger
applications will benefit more from the
graph computing the smaller
project tend to benefit the less but if
you're often times a smaller project
have a potential to grow in complexity
so at some point you may want to revisit
that decision
um
there are okay so i think we have the
questions answered so let's go through
the
the
the first example which i'm going to
walk through the
uh the key syntax of the julius
rooh dsl and the
atom
interface
that to interface with the traditional
programmer in a language so just one
quick point to make is that the atom is
also
a great way to control the granularity
of your your your node
your graph because you can have
a atom that does heavy processing a
heavy atom that means that your your
graph will have a fewer nodes for the
same task
or you can have atom that is a very
granular does a little bit work and then
your graph will have a lot more notes if
you have full control of switching the
logic between the
the number of nodes trade trade them off
between number nodes and what did happen
in each individual node
so here
uh
in this
tutorial we're just going to highlight
the key
uh syntax for julius
uh
rudisl and adam and show how easy it is
to
implement the
fibonacci sequence we shared earlier in
the in the benchmark
so
the julius
atom is a very simple
uh struct abstract struct
uh defined in julia so here is a very
simple atom that they defined to compute
the
weighted sum of arbitrary number of data
frames this will be used to compute the
fibonacci sequence
on data frames
um so the atom is a abstract interface
uh here we're using a sub
struct from the the base
atom it's called datum so this is the
most generic and commonly used use the
atom type it can capture any kind of
data processing or numerical computation
there are different types of atoms that
you can define so for example some items
interface are specialized for add joint
hours algorithmic differentiation aed
implementation but that is not the topic
of this part of the
the the workshop so if you're interested
you can get access to the
uh to the web environment and also look
at the
aed example and you'll get all the
detail there
so in this case you can see that the the
atom just have a very simple interface a
single function called for data take the
take that in this case datum object at
the first argument then take a arbitrary
number of data frames then just
internally does this we did the sum and
the return vector
so we choose the in we choose to define
the all the atom to return vectors to be
explicit that
the any item can return multiple objects
so
so if you want to return a a multiple
object in one shot it's very easy to do
following this interface
so here we can this is just plain
vanilla julia code nothing special and
from that you can easily see that's what
it's supposed to do when you have a few
data frames uh you can compute it with
some of them
also besides this
vanilla like plain vanilla giulia
way of declaring um datum we also offer
a
macro to declare the same item in a more
compact form
so this is a pure syntax sugar to make
it easier to write
atoms
the reason there is benefit for doing
this because
if in the future we have to make an api
change then if you write your item in
the plain vanilla julia code you have to
make corresponding changes if their
future api change
but if you use the data data macro then
we're just going to modify the data
macro in one place and all the
data you declared using this macro don't
have to be changed so there there is a
benefit of doing it using the macro so
it's recommended
and then we declare another
datum which is just a random data frame
with a different mean value specified as
a first parameter
so in this case
uh this is pretty much all the syntax we
have for the data it's pretty
straightforward
and
i i don't think requiring further
explanation the one point on to just
emphasize that the item interface is
implemented in all major programming
languages like python java.net
r like
what have you so make it very easy to
interrupt with libraries coded up in
other programming languages or plug them
you can easily plug all of them and mix
match them in in the graph
uh so this part is really the
the the key
part i want to explain this is the root
dsl syntax
that defines the the fibonacci type of
operation on random vectors
um so in this case as you can see that
first we use this
another julia macro add rules to define
the root dsl it take the namespace
this in this case namespace you can give
it any name
we call it sequence seq
so after name space is the beginning
block within this block you have a
isolated number of declarations
of your your rules so we call these
basic logic
unit rules so pretty much if you look at
the syntax for example if you look at
this core
recursion definition of the
root dsl
this part specifies the the output node
the name of the auto node it can take
parameters and that can take
this like a value-based templatized type
so basically the output node
is fully
it can be parameterized with different
types
and
inside you can have a beginning end or
if you just declaring one one line you
can drop at the beginning
so this part ties the
output
to a particular atom so basically this
says that
the operation to be applied in order to
generate this output is captured by this
item
and this item the square bracket
syntax will be directly translated into
a parenthesis at the wrong time so that
the constructor of that atom will be
called so therefore when
we change the square bracket to purposes
this gives you a direct way to create
that atom
as part of the graph
and then this
follow the item is followed by a list of
the upstream dependencies
of other nodes in order to
create that that atom
that sorry in order to create that
output node so in this case just the two
previous terms of the fibonacci sequence
it's very straightforward
as you can see that the the rule syntax
support the recursion
and also in this case
uh the second parameter basically
identify whether
this node is a
initial condition or not if it's the
initial condition then just does
something special like which just
created a random vector
for the for the data frame
so this is pretty much the core logic of
the the fibonacci sequence definition as
you can see like
uh it's pretty straightforward to read
there's no complex syntax features and
this pretty much captures like probably
the majority of the syntax available in
the in the root dsl
and you can see that this is a very
different from traditional programming
language as ordering that doesn't
doesn't make a difference so these are
fully declarative syntax so the the
rules are not executed one by one
instead
at the wrong time
we're going to recursively take
one of the rules and expand its uh
upstream dependency recursively so that
entire graph will be created on the fly
so the other two rules actually just for
convenience so if
a user didn't specify whether this is a
initial condition or not we just
automatically
uh insert it in this case the zero and
one are the two terms that are initial
condition
and if the user uh give a floating point
number just cast it to an integer and
call the other rules
so in this case you can see that
we support the
polymorphism so different rules can have
different behavior
and also like
this alias is a very useful atom that
just delegates this
basically create a reference
of this node to the input node so it
directly pass through
allow you to organize the rules in a
more readable manner by assign different
names
so this is pretty much all the syntax uh
majority of the syntax in the rudia so
as you can see it only takes like
probably 10-15 minutes to explain it's a
very minimal syntax don't have any of
the complex language features
so then later on we can see how these
rules are used to create the graph so in
this case
for example if you want to create a
fibonacci sequence
node with
parameter 3.2 so what we do is use a
fully qualified name with both the
namespace and the rule name so in this
case mapped to this
rule
and we
use this macro
to bind a concrete parameter to this to
this rule and once we bind it with the
concrete parameter
it become a
node ref type
so basically um a node graph is nothing
but a rule with every parameter binded
with concrete values so this i uniquely
identify a node in a graph because there
cannot be
if you have two nodes with same rule and
same parameter they are the same it's
really the same node they should only
exist once
in the in the graph it should not have
duplicates so we guarantee that there's
no duplications
and this is pretty much a very
straightforward way of assign names to
all the rules in your graph it's very
it's tied to the rule dslr definition
it's very convenient because allow you
to name any arbitrary rules
and
nodes in the graph
so once we have this
reference defined we just call this two
functions to get a a graph output
and
the result is like it's showing here so
we can also bring up a graph ui
so this is a very convenient interactive
web ui that we allow users to
visualize step by step how the data
is produced and how they flow through
the system and you can see that
we
this is pretty much like street leaf
three four they follow the rules first
we have a
uh
rule defined for following point number
converter integer number then we have
that integer number uh
like depend on a a
version with two parameter which is now
the initial condition and it
continuously gets expanded eventually
you hit the initial condition it's very
straightforward to define the graph like
this
also in the graph ui
uh we have a
also we can look at the rules
the dependency of the rules so these are
the really the relationship between the
four rules we have
specified
earlier this give a convenient view of
your your computation logic and also the
underlying
underlying
rule declaration the developer has has
written
so we already
mentioned that
this part um
so once we have the
node graph it's uniquely name a node in
the graph we also can take a hash of
that node draft produce a unique id
of the node
so that
the node can also be
uniquely identified
by the by hash id so in this case for
example if you want to directly query
these two nodes we don't have to search
the graph traversing the graph can just
directly
run them by pick up the names and and
directly ask what they do value
so in the next part
we're just going to show a
how to
handle
dynamic number of dependencies
because sometimes the number of upstream
dependency is unknown when you write the
rules it could depend on your your
parameters or could depend on some some
other
other intermediate calculation you you
do
uh this is very like a rich
we want to support this type of rich
dynamic behavior so for example in this
case if you want to compute all the even
terms the summation of all the even
terms of the fibonacci sequence we have
this
language
we have this like a syntax support of
three dots
to specify dynamic dependency so
basically anything
before the three dots have to return
either node ref or vector or node ref so
that the node graph or vector of that
will be taken as the dynamic dependency
of this node so for example in this case
when we declare we want to have all the
even
terms summed up
the dependency
on the on the previous node is a
variable like depend on the number of n
so in this case for example if you look
at
if you have n equal to five
in this case there are three values so
this basically this entire vector will
be replaced at the dependency of this
node so as a result using this syntax
feature we can create the dynamic
dependency like this like sum up all the
even terms of the fibonacci
sequence
also like
we you can declare local variables
between the beginning and end block so
this this time sometimes this can be
convenient if you want to do some quick
data manipulation processing before you
return the the
return the
datum definition and dependencies
so
yeah this is pretty much all the
dsl language feature i want to introduce
so probably it hasn't covered everything
but it covered probably
almost 90 percent of all the syntax we
offer in the rudia seo just a quick
word before we move to the next session
as you can see that these declarations
directly map to the graph construct that
is why it's so convenient and so
efficient for
creating large graphs as you can see
it's structurally it's like output node
uh upstream
input dependencies and what you want to
do on in order to create that
on this node the other creator output
so even though this syntax is very
limited
very minimal but you can see that they
can handle polymorphism it can handle
recursion can handle loops for example
you have a kind of branches in this case
we do have different behavior for
initial initial terms or non-individual
terms all of these rich language
features you may think you need actually
yeah i'm sure you don't need any of
those you just need this single playing
declaration of
of rules that follow the structure of
the graph and you can do everything you
could do in the traditional program
language
so
the next part we are going to show
introducing yet another uh very
important concept called the runtime and
and graph data
so so far we have covered the the
root dsl syntax and
how we can
use it to create
uh
graph logic and also how that can
interface
with the atom and to interface with your
traditional uh
style of programming using functions so
just having the the logic
completely defined is now to the full
story of enterprise system so under any
enterprise system have a rich set of
configuration
for
for runtime
uh so for example whether you want your
enterprise system to be like your system
to be distributed whether you want the
intermediate results to be cached
whether you want to compute
aad along the way or whether we want to
run the entire system in the batch or
streaming mode these
runtime configuration are not covered by
the your business logic or analytical
technology these are really how you want
to organize implement your your system
for the for the runtime behavior
so what's
uh tend to happen that for example in in
large banks
for example
uh since the if you take streaming and
batch as example since these two
different configurations have a very
different
requirements
of course streaming application wanted
to be fast and bad job we want to be
like a scale and really process large
number of trades very quickly so we end
up with often building like two separate
systems for batch and streaming because
their runtime behavior is totally
different
uh so in this case even though their
logic
ideally should be
their modeling and analytic logic
ideally should be different but they
have several implementations that drive
up that duplication drive up cost and
make it difficult to support oftentimes
your batch system and streaming system
can go out of sync because they may
follow different update schedule create
all kinds of problems so in this portion
we show how julius
graph engine handled this problem
generically
so basically besides root dsl and atom
that is really the two constructs you
need to define your entire business
logic we also follow
the
uh we also uh
like
we also offer the
another contract
called the graph data this really
encapsulates all the runtime
configuration behavior you may you may
want to do differently on the same logic
so here we support the three
runtime configuration of the box they
are all subtype of graph data so far we
have been showing the the usage of
generic data later i'm going to show a
example of stream data so the generic
data is really like a bad
converted for batch job it by default
have all the intermediate results cached
that is why when you go to the the graph
you can see the
you can see all the intermediate
results at your fingertips become very
convenient
so the stream data is really configured
for streaming use case
and the numerical data
this is for the
special
use case of adjoint algorithmic
differentiation or aed so if you want to
compute aed in your
end-to-end system
you're going to use the numerical data
it is the word have native aed support
um so the the
the
also another point i want to mention
that
you can derive
from this graph data and implement to
your own runtime behavior so for example
you may write a runtime behavior that
doesn't do caching or detending to
some of these
these things or
it's completely up to the user if if
they want to have a different use case
other than three-way support other bugs
so the next portion really showing how
easy it is to take the
uh fibonacci pipeline we build a very
simple pipeline turn that into a
stringing job so in this case to make it
more useful we
implemented item that
simply computed around the average of
all the data frames that are seen at the
at the
at this point
and
we can connect this new
data
uh using a rules basically says that uh
i can com i want to compute
i can compute any
nodes
i can connect to any nodes and compute
it's like a stream average in this case
this is a very interesting rule because
as you can see take a node graph as a
parameter
so
if you recall the node graph is nothing
but a particular node in the graph
so this actually declared generic
pattern says that this rule can apply to
any node in your graph and compute it's
like a running average if you're running
the streaming mode
so this is another like very useful
feature of julius through dsl which are
called high level rules
so you you don't have to declare like
always declare concrete rules but you
can also declare generic patterns so in
this case it's a generic pattern that
you can
basically connect to any node in the
graph that does its thing
and
this part
we specify how the streaming
should be sourced we take the first two
initial condition initial terms as a
source of streaming then we basically
say we have the fifth term and we're
going to connect this streaming rule to
that
node and we're going to run the
streaming process so as you can see that
to convert your
system into streaming you only need a
few lines of code
change uh specify the runtime
configuration then you get a streaming
system in this case we stream like 20
000
data frames through and it's very fast
like a 10 000 data frame only take point
a second you get
the average of this 10 000 running
average of these 10 000
uh
streamed the
data frames oh sorry twenty thousand
actually streamed two batches of twenty
thousand so in this case it's
effectively
uh it's effectively we're computing the
fifth terms of fibonacci sequence using
uh using the
montcalo simulation if you if you look
at this end-to-end
so now we can look at how we can bring
up the ui
and this is the output of the
streaming
as you can see that
the last node this is the running
average of all the previous previously
streamed nodes
and if you look at the previous node
this is the
value of the last
data frame that has been streamed
through
so therefore the accumulated effect are
showing in the in the last node and the
rest of the graph only cache the the
last value it has seen
so
this is pretty much like the
the the key
uh
highlights i want to want to go through
for raw dsl
and a very simple use case
of
a fibonacci sequence and also
uh how to turn that into a streaming use
case so basically the the takeaway here
that really the syntax of root dsl is
very simple
and it doesn't take much effort to learn
and use
and also it is very flexible it gives
you the ability to quickly turn your
system into batch or streaming mode
later on we are going to show how to use
the distribution in the next part of the
presentation
so by now i'm going to stop sharing my
my screen
and
let's see if there are any more
questions coming from the
pigeon hole
uh okay so there are a few questions let
me try to quickly
answer them uh
by the order of hopefully upvotes
uh
out of curiosity is the name julius
inspired from julian yes we we
we yes the name does come from julia
because the um the rudyard cell is
implemented
on top of julia as a
as a um
as a sort of
macro layer
and also
we do like
uh rely upon a lot of these julia
language features such as the multiple
dispatch
okay so
okay some of the question has been
answered by my colleagues
so
it's julius hiring yes we're hiring
where is the root dsl repository
so
the currently the rudiso repository um
is a is a private ripple so therefore
like if you log into our website a free
developer website you can have full
access to the functionality
oh there's a question about how easy it
is to reorder sequence
okay so i think these are probably
specific questions we'll leave it uh
we'll answer offline so the next portion
of the
workshop we're going to have
uh
we're going to
go through a
machine learning use case
hi hi can you hear me
okay
hopefully you're hearing fine
in this part of the workshop i want to
talk about machine learning with julius
graphene
and well for this i will share a
tutorial
on which we are going to solve a basic
machine learning workflow
so hopefully hopefully you are seeing my
screen now
well here we are going to be solving the
titanic
data set which is a well-known
machine learning problem to predict the
survival of the passengers of the
titanic
and for this we'll be using the
predefined rules and atoms available at
the julius data science package
and we will see how these rules cover
operations such as data loading
visualization and transformation and
then we are going to see the great
capability of integrating with another
language since we are going to train the
available python models
then we are going to use a high order
rule
to measure the performance of multiple
models and to tune the hyper parameters
of said models so hopefully that'll be
really interesting
the first thing to do is configure the
workspace importing the libraries that
we're going to use
and here's some jupiter workspace
configuration
and the first thing to do we declare the
config variable that is needed at the
moment of the graph creation
with this parameter you can set a
project name in case that you need to
run more than one graph you can identify
the graph associated to this project
with this parameter
so let's begin and load the data
for this we are creating our first node
reference here through the rule dsl
reference macro
and we are referring to the rule ds
namespace and we have two rules that
support the loading of data in this case
i have my data on a csv file but also we
could load from a url
and these parameters here are actually
passed in the background so the csv.jl
real function
with returns a data frame with the
titanic dataset
and this is the name of my file and this
is whether it has headers
and with this parameter here we are
setting a label for this node on the
graph so it will be easy to identify
um
so next we want some information about
our data in order to know what we need
to do to work with it
and for that in julia and also in python
in pandas we have the describe function
which gives you statistics on the
columns
so here this rule data summary what it
does is to take another node reference
and it will apply the describe function
to the output of this rule
in this line here we are creating an
instance of a blank graph with our
configuration
and in here at the calc forward call we
are computing this graph
here we indicate the name of the of the
instance we created and here we pass
like this the final output of the graph
uh the final node which is this one the
last we declare and since every node
must have information about the
predecessors about the dependencies
the graph can be computed recursively
now once the graph the graph is computed
we can get data from any node that we
want with the getdata function
we specify the name of the graph and the
name of the node that we want the output
and since every data must return a
vector as an output here with the one we
indicate we want the output that's on
inside the first element of that vector
in this case a data frame
and this is the result of applying the
describe function to the titanic dataset
we have the names of our columns and
some statistics
and the first thing to do we analyze
this and see that we have missing values
and we need to fill those in order to
work with this
um
well maybe carrying here has too many
missing values this is most of our data
set missing so we are not trying to
infer this variable we are going to drop
it but we are going to fill embark and
edge columns
and for this we have the field missing
rule under the ds namespace again
and this rule takes a node reference and
a dictionary with the uh
with the names of the columns we want to
fill the missing values as keys
and here the values of this dictionary
is the function that we want to apply
the method that we want to apply to this
column and this will operate over the
whole column and fill the missing values
with the result
we use the same rule as before the data
summary to compute a summary of that
and we see that the missing values of
embark and age are both
gone and well now we can
maybe analyze a typical values or things
like that but let's say that our data
cleansing is done and proceed to feature
engineering
and for future engineering well we want
to select the features for our models to
train with
and for example we may want to create a
new columns from the existing ones
so in this case we have the fair column
which is a numerical one
and
we want to normalize it for example uh
subtracting the mean dividing by the
deviation and now we have a new
distribution for our fair column center
is zero and with one as a deviation
another thing we may want to do is
reduce dimensionality for example in
this case this column is the amount of
relatives a passenger has
sorry this column is the total amount of
relative a passenger has on the titanic
since this represents the total amount
of siblings and this the total amount of
parents or children that are on board
sorry milan
some people are asking to enlarge the
screen so if you can zoom in and leave
it oh sorry sorry i wasn't really seeing
um
maybe that's too much that is it
readable now
yeah i think it's much better
so thanks okay maybe we can hide this as
well and maybe enlarge a bit more i
don't know
okay thanks maro
so the next thing uh after we declare uh
these as a quotation here we have two
expressions
with some information about the line of
declaration of this code as well
and these are the new features that we
are going to add then the features that
we do not want to use we need to declare
instead of an array
as expressions as well these are the
names of the columns that we are going
to drop
and if we want to transform it a data
frame we can use the call transform rule
that allow us to pass a node reference
with our data then set a name for our
operation and then pass the new features
and the drop features
and here we will have a node reference
with our new data frame we will compute
a data summary again from that node
reference and
we can see
that now our new columns are here i
probably should have dropped these three
as well to reduce dimensionality and
since now we are creating the new ones
but let's continue like this this is an
example
here the mean is now zero and is the sum
of these two
so
now we can compute our graph and see the
whole
workflow through the
through the nodes information and
what's interesting here is that all the
input and output
of each node is caching memory so with
the call with the code of this cell we
can here pass the name of our graph
and we can visualize it through the wave
ui much better
and
slowly
ready to load
you of course i also should check on the
questions
sorry allow me to rerun all of the cells
again
this is kind of lagging it probably
through my internet connection
let's access again to the tutorial
and
i run all of the cells
okay there's the server running
yes you you can run all the souls again
just on there
yes i think right now they are running
uh we are going to go through this again
really sorry about that
probably had my my kernel going for too
long and people is connecting so
you can always restart the kernel if you
encounter an error like this
um
another thing to mention is for example
if you change a definition of a rule of
a graph
it's a better practice to restart the
kernel and run everything again
so now hopefully it will load
great
now we see our first no declaration that
is here
and here we can see the atom that's
applied to this to this node in this
case it's alias the alias
atom allow us to refer the output of a
different rule in this case we are
referring to this one
that is performing and the creation of
an atom that outputs the data frame that
we passed
then we made a summary of that then we
filled the missing values and you can
always see the output here
and then a summary and then again future
engineering and a summary of that
so it's really easy to trace and debug
what data we are going to use to train
our models uh here we have uh
everything is cached for every node so
it's not like you run these ones and
then you don't really get explainability
on why your model gave certain results
you can always debug really easily like
this
and the next thing to do is to train our
python models and for that i want to
present uh this pie train rule sorry
this pie train atom
that works as an interface with python
here you can pass a full name of a
python class to use and here the options
is a dictionary with the arguments to
that to that python class
and this step is creating the atom and
structure with these fields
and at the moment of the computation we
call the forward data function of an
atom and we pass the training data
and since the rule dsl supports multiple
dispatch here we can use polymorphism to
define different behavior for a
different type or for variable
in this case we have the classifier
train rule
that we call the desired
pi train atom that we want to use
depending on the model that we want to
train
so now we will see a higher order rule
that will allow us to train all of these
models at once and measure the
performance on different metrics
and for that
first we need to declare a classifier
spec object classify respect variable
that
will contain data about the models that
we want to train and also about the x's
and the y's of our problem and also what
some indexes used for validation and
training and the name of the target
column
so first we clear all of the models that
we want to train like this as as pairs
uh indicating the dictionary this will
be then the the options variable here
so these are arguments for these python
models only all in scale learn library
as you can see here
also exposed
then we are here declaring our target
column
here we want to select a portion of our
data to use as validation and some other
portion to use as training
so we can take a node reference which is
our clean data
and here select a fraction of the code
that will be used for validation and the
rest will be used for training
so with all that information declared we
can create or classify respect
variable
structure
passing the models and also or or clean
data here notice that we are only
passing the clean data and the
operation that we want to pass to it is
passed
separately on a tuple here is the name
of the transformation we defined earlier
and the
the new features uh also we are passing
the name of the target column and the
validation indexes
so at res at this point it's really easy
to define different classifier spec
objects for example to train
different models with different
transformations
so it's really easy to reproduce
multiple experiments with this
then here we define an array with the
metrics that we'll be using and create a
new node reference with a classifier
metric higher the rule
this rule would say or classify a spec
object with all of the information of
the models and our problem
and then we compute a dependent node for
one of for each one of these metrics
here
so we can compute the graph with this
node that we declare as a final output
the classifier metric
and we see here that this is all the
time that it took to train all of the
models and and
calculate the the performance
so
yeah here all of the of all of the
necessary classifier train
rule has been called
and if you want to retrieve a result of
the graph
you can create a node reference for
example this node reference is a
dependent node from this one as this one
calculated each one of these separates
so you can
instantiate a concrete instance of a
node and then search it on the graph
with the with the get data function
and if we see the output of this here we
are just computing uh all of the output
of this node that we should check
now this is a dictionary with both in
sample and outsample metrics
and
both point to a data frame
with the metrics for each model here we
are computing all of the metrics
together in a new data frame
uh what as expected we have much higher
performance
for the in-sample metric that is using
the training data to predict
and this is how all of our models
perform already they are trained and we
can see that
how that happened through the through
the graph
so
we here we have our data loaded
here we made the missing values
imputation and we passed that clean
source of data to our classifier spec
structure
and here it it just managed to though a
split of the columns in the x's and the
y's here you can see it saves the axis
and the wise by separate
it applies the feature engineering to
the axis
and then memorize the non-numerical
values to train the models
then again we use our clean data to
select a random
number of indexes for validation
and those indexes
are used to split the data for training
and validation
here is where the model uh training is
happening
and here we are computing the metrics
and what's really nice here is that for
example you can define as i mentioned
multiple transformations to train
multiple models and it's really easy to
see what
one model is being trained with because
for example you can select
show precedence you just right click and
show precedence
and you see the full lineage of this
node
so now it's really easy to trace all of
the workflow and debug
how your machine learning model is being
trained
then let's continue
here we see that we can compute the
total amount of nodes on our graph there
are 83 nodes
and now let's use the high order rule
hypertune to turn the hyper parameters
of a desired model
here we are creating node references to
tune all of these
models
we are passing again or classifier spec
structure
and here we could pass again a
dictionary with the arguments for these
models in case we want to fix an hyper
parameter or pass another argument
here we are selecting the metric and
here
the last argument is uh the hyper
parameters that we want to
tune
so
here we will perform a grid search
between these values going 50 by 50
between 50 and 200 for the numbers of
trees computed in this case
and like that and this rule will return
the metric uh
performance for each one of these
combinations
here we are just declaring another node
reference that alice's
as we have seen the alias atom
just references the output of another
node here we are referencing the output
of all of these nodes
so if we compute our graph with this
final output
recursively all of this is going to be
computed
and here we select for example we see
that we created a new graph and here for
example we are going to this dependent
node which is this one
the gradient boost model so we are going
to see the performance for that
for all of the hyper parameters that we
wanted to sweep
so here i'm not going to type deep on
which perform best but we could say for
example that we want a similar
value between the in-sample and
outsample metrics because a wide
difference between this may mean that
it's overfitting too much
for example uh this one is uh widely
different from this outsample matrix so
for example this one here
maybe better i don't know you should
analyze as well
and
then we can see our final graph
on the web ui again
and this
looks much simpler
than before
we see that our
classifier spec creation is the same
but here
we should be training our models since
we created a new graph
with this output so if we actually check
at these nodes we see we have an inner
graph
that we can inspect
and we see all of the training of the
models is actually contained inside of
that graph
inside of that node sorry
so
for that node actually this was the
input and this was the output and all of
this was hidden on the background
so it's really easy to
finally
trace all of the all of the
inputs and output for each one of the
nodes
finally as a conclusion we can say that
we are provided with rules that allow us
to solve a machine learning basic
problem
but of course you can also define your
own
rules and your own items with your
desired statistical operations or
whatever you may need and you can use
the local
macro syntax to add new rows and items
also it's really easy to debug or models
how get some explainability of the
results we have since uh once you run
the graph the the
all of the workflow will
data will be there uh cache in memory
for you to check
and
also it's released to reproduce multiple
experiments with multiple uh
transformations different
transformations
and those are really useful tools for
this
also there's to remark that you do not
need to throw away your work in another
language or you can use
another language is really useful
libraries
since we provide
the capability of creating atoms that
work as an interface as mentioned with
another languages such as r java c plus
plus in this case we see that we are
provided with an item that already allow
us to train and model on scale learn on
python
and also this scales really well
probably uh one of the most important
features is that you can
connect your machine learning pipeline
to a
really
high
i mean a really large scale data
analysis
for example you may have
a really complicated data gathering
process for example or you may want to
predict something that's happening live
and for that you can stream data
really integrate your machine model
training and prediction inside a full
data pipeline
so that that's a really useful tool to
remark
uh well next
my colleague marrow is going to explain
how to
distribute a task
which is useful for example in cases
that your
your data does not fit into your memory
or that you want to
use capability of multiple machines to
perform a task so we are going to see
how to distribute
thanks for your listening
thanks milena we will give some some
seconds uh
in case there's a question regarding
this
this last talk
so you can you can also use a pigeon
hole to
to refer your questions there and of
course
we will be answering
okay
so let me start sharing my screen
please let me know if you hear me well
okay cool
amazon okay so i will start now uh
thank you thank you very much all of you
my name is mauro coco i'm part of truly
starts team
this this talk will be
about how to build the mapreduce generic
pipeline uh by using our rule dslr so
to summarize briefly how this talk is
going to be organized first we will do
an introduction on on the mapreduce
programming model
then we will jump onto our julius web
server
and we will start building
just from scratch a generic pipeline and
we will use a word count example to
guide ourselves
on how to build it
then we we will show also some other
examples on how to reuse this generic
pipeline to tackle another problems
in the end i will i will be showing how
easy is to make distribution based on
the same code we we would
develop
together so uh
let's first talk about mapreduce
problem this this uh a programming model
that was first introduced by two
researchers on google on 2004 uh
this was uh
discussed under a paper called mapreduce
simplified data processing on large
clusters
so i don't know if you are all familiar
with with this but i will try to explain
it as as best as i can
so this is a strong
a programming model strongly oriented to
parallel and distribution distributed
execution
which is
particularly good to tackle large amount
of data and computing
and it is built to to to be simple fast
scalable and fault resistance
and the first implementation of this was
uh
was introduced to to hadoop so so you
can find
the implementation of maproduce on these
on these tools as well
so what's what's the idea of the
mapreduce programming model so
the idea is that you can split your data
source into multiple batches
uh
and
these multiple watches can be sent to
several workers so the idea is that
when you apply mapreduce you're usually
thinking on a on a cluster context of
multiple machines
so these first workers will will apply a
mapping function which is common to all
of them and it's going to be applied to
every batch of data
then a shuffling process will occur
which it's basically redistributing the
outputs of the mouth and the mapping
process based on certain keys that must
be provided at this step
and in the end the output of the
shufflers
that have organized the
mapping output based on the keys
this output will be
will
be applied with a reducing function
which
will basically
apply the same process to all of the
batches and finally give us the final
output so at this point this sounds very
abstract and let's see how this looks
with an example
so imagine you have a large collection
of
files with many words on them
and you want to apply this
mapreduce pipeline to
count the
number of occurrences of each of the
words in the in the document
so you can start with a data patch like
this one you will split it into several
batches
then
you will send to these watches to the
workers and you will apply a mapping
process to all of them so in this case
the mapping
will be just
generating a vector of pairs where each
pair is going to be the word itself and
a number one
then the shuffling process will combine
all the same keys together into a single
node
and this node will be transferred to the
reducers where the counting of the
number of accuracies for each word it's
going to be occurring
in the end the final result will be
prompt as a single node
so i'm going to recap a little bit on
the syntax
of our rule dsl
so let's first focus on how to define
the the rules so we are going to be
using this add rules macro
where we provide this namespace which is
particularly
good for organizing our rules and
avoiding name clashing among them
then we define the rule name we define
the rule arguments that it can take and
we can define now the body of the rule
so here we can add some additional code
to make transformation for example to
the rule arguments
uh or whatever you need
and in the end you must provide an item
so you provide the atom name here the
the attributes that this
atom
accepts which are basically the
attributes of the structure behind the
item
and then you you must provide the
dependent nodes
here between parentheses which are
basically notes based on other rules
okay
uh so the atom itself is going to be the
responsible for com for
processing all the data that is
given here on the dependent nodes
okay so the idea here on this
on this talk is to build
a rule like this one we have here
which we will call mapreduce and it's
going to accept the batches of data we
will provide
then it's going to accept a generic
mapper and
and then a shuffler as well and a
generic reducer
uh well we will see how to make the
definition of this rule
so
here it's important to mention that this
rule that we are going to build
all the dependencies all the all the
arguments here are of type rule uh dsl
node wrap so
it's important to mention at this point
what it's a node ref so it's basically a
data structure that refers to another
node in the graph okay so
we need to mention that every node in
the graph is created by a specific rule
so
the dependency here on another node can
be understood as the dependency on the
underlying rule so a rule
with a
with an overhead parameter or many of
them is called a high order rule because
it defines a generic pattern whose
behavior is it's going to depend on the
on the other rules yeah that you will be
defining here
so this is extremely powerful in order
to define abstract and high level logic
and behaviors um and this is
for example what we want to do at this
mapreduce pipeline so
we can also pass a high order rule as a
parameter to another rule and this can
lead to creating even more higher order
rules so it can be as abstract as you
want so this ability to nest higher the
rules is one of the reason why the rule
dsl is both low code which is one of the
parts of stellar and it's expressive and
this is one of the biggest benefits of
graph computing
okay so
let me now jump after this introduction
to
to our tutorials uh
site
that you can you can also access
and we will be working on this mapreduce
tutorial which is
number three and in the end i will also
show a little bit uh the fourth tutorial
which is on distributed machine learning
which is
basically reusing this pipeline we will
build together
more you may want to hide the message on
your on the bottom of your screen um
streaming art is sharing your screen
around the hideout
thank you
thank you
okay so you can
still go through this introduction
yourself and it's basically explaining
what i've been showing before
we'll start from the generic mapreduce
gear let me
endorse it uh
i think this the size
of the screen it's okay so let me know
if it is too
too small i will endorse it
so the first thing we we need to to do
here is to
start defining the mapping process and
we will start guiding ourselves through
this workout example so imagine you have
a
sentence like murray has a lamp
and the mapping process for for this
particular problem will be transforming
this into a vector of pairs like this
one we have here okay
so
uh along this
uh
this talk we will be using this apply
function atom
which is a
really handy item that can accept
a particular function and its parameters
and then apply uh apply this function to
to any kind of data
that is related to this
so
this apply function item is defined on
data science package
that is on on julius
so so you can use it
whenever you want
so the idea now is
first we are going to
to load our libraries
and we will define the word map function
that
that is basically transforming the
sentence into a vector of birth like we
we've said before
and the rule here for the mapper it's
going to accept a data batch
that is going to be a node ref and a
mapping function
which in this case for the world count
example is this word world map function
here
so you see we use the apply function
nation we provide the map function as an
attribute for it and then the data
node ref is provided here as a dynamic
dependency
so by doing this
we can
imagine you you
already have defined the several batches
here
and we'll see how we can define that
so you for each batch there you can
create a node ref based on this mapper
rule we have just defined
provide this batch as an argument and
then the mapping function which in this
case is a word count
and then we we can define another rule
which is mapreduce which can take the
all the batches all the mappers all the
shufflers and reducer
so this could be a
an approach for for this problem but
it's actually a problematic because it
require
it's put it's putting much wording to
ensure the consistency because we have
to define all the mappers all the
sharpness and reducers and each of them
are based on the previous one so
uh it's gonna be easier to build it in
another way and we will see how we can
do that
so the mapper
it it can be defined
without passing the first argument
and that is because we can use this
prepend function that is defined here
that allows us to
to put the first argument that in this
case is the batch of data
later on when when doing the mapreduce
rule definition okay
so this idea of avoiding passing the
first argument to to the mapper shuffler
and reducer will be uh used along this
uh
this this
tutorial
and
and the data batches will be provided at
the mapreduce
stage okay
so let's now define uh
our
batching rule so this that rule
will be accepting
for example a sentence and then
um
[Music]
we will use the apply function item
again the function that we will apply to
this is just the identity so this is
basically transforming a sentence into
an old graph so it will accept the
the sentence here
as an attribute because it's not a null
ref yet
and
so here we will start for example
defining the
our data source which are a couple of
sentences then we define our batches
from all the sentences
and then we can define this mapper
node based on the mapper rule but you
may see that we are avoiding passing the
first argument
so
to note that we are using this
underscore notation which basically
means that we are not passing the first
argument to
to them
so we can now use the prepend function
to illustrate how we can use it to pass
the first argument to to our mapper
so we can create a vector of no ref by
using the mapper rule
i'm using the perpend function to
give this input to
for each batch
so we can run all this
and and here this particular code is
just for transforming the node labeling
which is
really good to have a better
understanding on the graph so i will not
enter into the details of how this is uh
written but
you you can take a look and
it's really handy to to do this
so here
the note has been built for this pretty
simple task and you can take a look on
on the jupiter notebook or you can go to
the web ui as well
um
yeah i will run again all day all these
because after 15 minutes it's
it's going down so i will
restart the kernel
and run all the cells
sorry for this
yeah so now we can see it
so it's a pretty simple graph where we
have defined the three batches uh and
then
the mapper has been applied to each of
these
batches
so you can also see the information here
and it's pretty simple
okay so after the the the mapping
process
the we have to define the shuffling
process and then the mapping process as
well so i will not now enter into the
details as we have done with a with a
map
mapper but i will mention briefly
how this is built so the the first thing
is that the shuffler needs to take the
output from the mappers and split them
into multiple chunks by certain key
values that have been computed in the
map data
so
in our mapping process we've said that
for the word count example the keys are
the the word themselves okay so we have
to
shuffle and combine all the same words
together in into single into single
chunks that they then can be graphed by
the reducer
so we have to move these chunks around
that so all the data with the same key
is gathered together
and we have to con concatenate all the
chunks at the gathering node to to
recover the full collection of data
so we need to define this split by key
function which we have to provide here
which is the key function we are using
so which is the function that applies to
the mapper will extract the keys so
we will see
in our case it's pretty simple
and by using this function we can define
a split by key rule which is based on
this function
then we can define a select key node and
a merge by key node so these three nodes
are pretty simple and are going to be
used here on the shuffler
so
all all these three rules defined
previously
are used here
and they
basically are doing exactly the same
process that we have described here on
top
okay so you can later take a look into
this it's not complex it's pretty
similar to the mapper
so now we can define our shuffler node
based on this rule and we will provide
the mappers
uh
and so this is the input for them
this is the the function we are going to
use to extract the keys from the from
the mappers so the first function is
taking the the first value on a pair and
remember we had vector of pairs
where the first argument was a word and
here this is a limitation at this point
we have to provide all these all the
keys that can appear on our data set and
why is the limitation because we can
know beforehand which are the the
several keys that may appear in our data
set so
bear this in mind in the end of this
part we will see how to deal with this
and we will completely solve it
so
now just to make it easier we can see
this graph in our web ui
and see
which are the additional transformations
and nodes we have added so the previous
step was finishing here on the mapper
and now we are adding this shuffling
process
which are
these four stages here so the first one
first one is splitting the mappers by
keys
then we are selecting by keys and
combining
all the results together so you can see
words are
grouped together here
and then they are returned as a final
result
but the reducers that we are going to
define now uh will start from this one
here okay so bear this in mind this this
node will disappear in network
in the following graph which i will show
so the reducing step is pretty similar
to the mapper we are going to define a
reducer rule which will take the
the output of the shuffler and
will accept a reducing function which in
this case for the word count example is
nothing but counting the number of
occurrences of the world on the shuffler
okay so we use the same apply
functionality
and we provide the shuffled
as a dynamic dependency again
so for the world count example here we
define the the reducing function
it's a really simple function
and now we are
able to
to define our map reduce
finally
so
this rule will accept the several
batches we can define based on the batch
rule we defined previously
then it will accept the mapper shuffler
and reducer
in in the way we define with an
underscore okay so avoiding passing the
first argument
so inside the rule we will use the
prepend function to pass the first
argument
to it then we will use it again to pass
the the mappers to the shufflers and
then we are going to use the same
prepend function to pass all the
shufflers to the reducers
and then we will combine all the results
in into a single node by using the merge
function
so now we can define
with an underscore the shuffler mapper
and reducer so here you may see the
there's no data being passed
but the first function
and the keys for the shuffler the word
map function for the mapper and word
reduced to the reducer so this
definition is pretty simple then we
define the mapreduce node
and here we pass this the the batches
the mapper shuffle and reducer as we
mentioned before
so we can now create the graph and run
it
and we can see it on the web ui
okay so
we mentioned here it's a mapping process
this is a shuffling process up to this
point
and now we are applying a reducing
operation to each of these batches and
we finally get the the final node here
okay so this reducers are just counting
the number of accuracies and returning
it as a as a pair
so as i mentioned before the limitation
regarding the shuffler was that we
needed to provide
all the possible keys in our data set
and that is impossible in in
a real
application so
the way of solving this is by using the
hash and remainder functions
so we mentioned that we need we needed
to provide a function to extract the
keys from the mappers we were using the
first function
and this first function can be then
hashed
and the output of this hash can can
can be used to apply this remainder
function with a particular number that
will give us the number of shufflers we
are going to use
and why is that because
while applying this this remainder
function the possible values that we
will have are the collections here from
0 to 2. so if you
apply the remainder function with 3 so
the possible values are zero one or two
okay
so
imagine you have you have a value n then
the possible values are from zero to n
minus one okay so
this is how we
we can solve this problem because we
still use this first function
but by using the hash and remainder
function together we know which are the
possible keys that
that are are going to be used
so let's now take a look at how this
graph looks like
and you may see now the difference is
that previously we were selecting by the
words themselves but now we are using
the select uh we are selecting by these
integers okay
so
as i mentioned before the number of uh
of shufflers now
are three
because that's the argument we have used
for the remainder function so this can
be later on pass as a as a parameter
so
here you can see for example that this
know that two words
are
going to the same node so the reducer
function needs to
to deal with these uh two values in the
same node properly okay
and you may see this this reducer
function is well defined and the
mapreduce node
has the correct answer as in the
previous example okay
okay so
now we can redefine our split by key
split by key rule here and we can
redefine it
by using our hash and remainder
functions and you may see that here the
argument n is provided
so so you can select the number of
shufflers you can you can use
okay so any questions up to this point
okay so uh
i will now show you
uh how to
apply this same mapreduce pipeline to
solve another problem
and
another interesting problem is
the finding friends uh
problem so imagine you have a
social network where
you want to know which are the common
friends between
two specific users
so you may have this information here
uh
so imagine you have friend users a to e
and you have uh
this info information for each of each
of them so you have for a you have you
know that the friends are b c d
and for b you know that the friends are
a c t and e
so if you want to find the the
difference in common for each of them
you may see that if you only count with
the information of a
you you can say that difference in
common between a and b
may be
c and d
and if you see the information from b
you can say that the
the friends in common are c d and e okay
these are the possible values for each
of them
so the mapper
to solve this problem needs to take into
account which are the possible values
for each of the difference based on the
information on
on on
on the users okay
and then
so this is this is fine here on the on
the mapping function
yeah you can then take a look on how
this is built
and the reducing function
is basically
computing the intersection of these sets
of these subsets so
you may see that the correct answer to
find the friends in common between a and
b
is the section between c and the subset
cd and cde okay
so
you can you can use these functions to
define your mapper and reducer then the
shuffler will will use the first
function as well um
and we can run this
this whole
graph and see the output
okay
so
okay so now you can see the graph i will
go into some details to to
highlight how this works so you can see
that in the mapping process
for each of the friends that
um
for each of the users sorry that are the
several batches
you you apply a mapper and you compute
which are the possible friends in common
that a friend and these users
may have okay so you compute that for
all of them
then you split by keys
and you combine
all all together here on the shuffling
process and you apply the reducer to
take the intersection of these
of these outputs
and then you combine all the results
together in the in a single node and you
may see here for a and b that the result
is correct the friends in common c and d
okay
so
let's go back
so here it's another example it's a
group by example i will i will not show
it now because i prefer to save some
time to show you the the
distributed machine learning pipeline
briefly
but you can take a look it's basically
the same same
logic applied you have to define
a mapping function and a reducing
function and then you can
you can solve the problem so
the good thing about this pipeline is
that the user only needs to think about
which is the mapping and which is the
reducing process that they need to apply
to some of the the particular problem
they are dealing with okay
so
yeah you may see here it's a graph
okay
so
now before before showing how we can
make the distribution uh
of the previous pipeline let's let me
talk about some advantages of the of
julius graph
so in particular i want to make some
comparisons uh against uh function
composition because you may you may find
some similarities uh between
higher order rules in our rule dsl we
with
functions uh with high order functions
in languages like haskell for example
so
the first things i want to mention is
that while using higher order rules
this doesn't create
typical stacks and the result is nothing
but another graph okay
so this ensures that to the developer to
visualize and debug
to be a
really easy process while
if you are using a function composition
you need to use a debugger to access the
intermediate results and call sequences
and this is a much complex
process to do
so another thing is that the resulting
graph composition can be automatically
distributed without any code change and
you will see that this is really easy in
just in a few minutes
uh if you want to do the same
with the
traditional functional code
this is not really easy to to to make it
automatically or efficiently at the same
time
then
the graph composition is much more
flexible so once you build the graph you
can run it in different modes like
yellow explained before so you can use
both batch and streaming
modes to
to basically the the same
case without many code modifications
and this is basically impossible uh to
to do in this way with traditional
functional programming
and the last thing is that
while graph compositions can mimic
function composition the reverse is not
true and the mapreduce is a good example
of this
so let's now focus how to make the
distribution of our map to reduce
pipeline
we will see how easy is to do this
so
the first things we need to do is to
define some configurations and on top
but we're not entering into the little
of this it's basically the same for any
project you you're dealing with
so you just have to repeat this code
and here we start our local master
service and here we define the number of
workers that we are going to use
so this can be done basically in two
ways we can use a cluster with monitors
or like what
in this case i'm showing we can mimic
the cluster behavior by using the
several course
level on our computer okay so in this
case i'm going to use three cores
available on the cpu i'm using
uh the code for any of these cases is
basically the same
at this url we are going to see the the
outputs and the
this is the web ui
and
the first thing is to
to
import the the modules you are going to
use so the difference here is that you
need to use this macro remote the valve
and you have to provide this connection
to the graph okay so this is a remote
graph proxy object defined here you have
to provide it in in order to make the
connection
but the code is going to be the same
then to add rules you need to provide
this ad roots macro as we used
previously but the difference is that
you don't you don't only need to provide
the namespace
but the
the connection to the
to the remote proxies also
you need to provide it
so after this you can make the rule
definitions like we did before and you
may see that this is an exact copy of
the code above yeah so any any
modifications have been done
and
then for any arbitrary code like
functions or structure you may need to
define
like the prepend function the split by
key will reduce
whatever the node labeling display so
any function
can be defined
by using this remotable macro so this is
basically making the connection with the
workers
so now we can use this
provide the same data source as before
create several batches define
the number of shufflers we want to use
here
is the parameter and passed
and we can
we can now run the the computation but
an
interesting thing here is that because
we are doing distribution
we can let the user to
to say which are the notes that
he wants the these two distribution
tasks to base
on okay so
uh the most efficient way to distribute
this you will see
immediately in the graph is that
you can base the distribution and split
by keynotes and the reducer nodes so
this is going to be distributing the the
task among workers efficiently
after doing this you can dispatch all
the job by using this
this function and the computation will
be run again you can see the
the
this
display here or you can go to the web ui
that was on this url
see if it loads otherwise i will have to
run it again
i will run it again
yeah i will close
all these tabs
yeah this way it will take
just a few seconds because it it's
running all the previous computations
but eventually
yeah
it's almost there
okay
so here it's starting the
the service
and then it it will
it will send all this code to the
workers
yeah it's ready
and the computation
meanwhile i will restart this corner as
well so i can show you the distributed
machine learning as
well okay
so now i can i can show you this
okay
so now you can see
that this is basically the the first
problem the word count
problem i showed you
and the one we have used to
to build the mapreduce pipeline
and here you can see that different
colors appear so what does this mean is
that
each color is a
different worker
so you can see that
because we
we specified split by key to
to make the distribution on the
the
the graph have been distributed among
the several workers efficiently and also
the reducer
has been specified
at this stage and also the the task is
efficiently distributed but of course
during the shopping process there's some
shipment of data across and
you can't avoid that and it's okay
okay so
this is pretty
all from the bump reduce
pipeline and you can see that we have
built a generic mapreduce pipeline from
scratch
just by using 10 rules in our rule dsl
and 20 additional lines of code for
defining some functions so
here the the the results speak
themselves
we have
done it in a
in a single core
process but then we could easily
distribute it among several workers uh
just without any code transformation so
this is this one of the biggest benefits
of using our rule dsl
and the last thing i wanted to show
is our next tutorial which is called
distributed machine learning
and this
i will not show all this code i will
simply
show you how this is built so here we
define a simple machine learning
pipeline like milena did in in our
previous example
uh
we also defined how to do some
down sampling
sorry i forget to mention that this
tutorial is based on
on this
popular blog post that is called
training models when data doesn't fit in
memory which is describing how to use
tasks to to use it to create a backing
pipeline for machine learning um
so here we will show how how to build
the machine learning pipeline we with
bagging
still without distribution
uh
and here in the end
we show how to use uh
our
rule dsl to distribute this machine
learning pipeline but the good thing
about this is that
we are reusing the mapreduce pipeline
where the mapper in this case
is nothing but
machine learning training and validation
and the reducing stage is combining all
these multiple models into a more
powerful and robust
model which is basically bugging all of
them
and you can also see on this tutorial
that we are both using batch and
streaming mode uh
thank you it's the streaming in the end
and if we refer to this uh
to to the web ui now you may see that
the streaming the string uh output is is
displayed
so here the
you can see
on this tutorial that all the mapper is
this
is this process here
which is training and validation server
several models
in a streaming way and
here all the validations are are
combined and the mapreduce is is
basically providing
the final output
so you may see on this last node
that
several records of the score
are computed
and here you can see that the score is
getting better
as you start bugging more and more
trained models
okay so this is pretty all from from my
side of course i'm more than happy to
answer all the other questions and that
may arise at this
stage or later
so thank you all of you to to your
attention
thank you mauro
yeah so just quickly want to recap what
uh
mauro has illustrated so basically what
the moral has shown that
you can write
generic rules
and
without even considering the
complication of distribution once those
rules are written you can use julius
graph engine to automatically distribute
that to multiple workers without any
modification code change that is
tremendously beneficial beneficial and
save a lot of time just imagine how you
can do this in a traditional programming
way if you write a complicated function
that needs a distribution that can
require
major engineering effort to make it run
fast and optimally in a distributed
setting
so
um
again like if you have any more
questions please feel free to ask on the
on the pigeonhole link uh we're going to
answer it
uh like optimistically and also
hopefully we'll leave plenty of
questions in the end for qa
so in this section of the
workshop
i'm just going to show a another example
which shows how large scale
graph computation can be handled and
distributed
so
i'm going to share my screen
oh
sorry i'm sharing the wrong screen
okay so hopefully the right screen is
shared
um
all right so
here we're just um so far we have been
um showing some examples in
uh machine learning and data processing
in this example want to really quickly
illustrate
what is a large competition looks like
using our julius graph engine so in this
case we are showing a
application
that price a large
book of derivative trades so it's a
hundred thousand of uh derivative trades
and the entire graph
uh is a like a hundred more than a
million
nodes large
as you can see that the graph is too
large to to fit into a single page but
we allow
easy navigation
for the user to drill down to different
parts of the graph
and visualize the every intermediate
results if
if the developer want to see so in this
case for example you can again like even
with a million nodes you can easily
trace
uh the various intermediate results
and again the distribution is handled
generically you haven't done anything
special just to distribute this
particular problem all of this
distribution capability
and lineage like a visibility
ui all of these are generic applied to
any problem you can code up using
through dsl and
and atoms
in this case for example
we're using uh four different workers to
distribute this
relatively large graph and you can see
the the distribution is highly optimal
because in this case you can see that
there is an entire block of dependent
nodes that are all allocated to the same
worker so this minimizes the data
transfer between different
between different workers so that by
clustering the relevant node in the in
the same work actually dramatically
improve the performance the reason we
can do this type of optimization is also
enabled by by the root dsl because root
dsl gave us very easy way to name a
particular node in the graph therefore
can distribute the graph at much bigger
chunks instead of
some other platform have to distribute
the node one by one which turned out to
be much less efficient
um so
so this is a uh one example of handling
large computation
uh by actually like a milling node graph
is binomi by no means reaching our
limitations so we can routinely handle
graph as large as hundreds of millions
of nodes that is not a problem at all so
really want to emphasize that the
solution is
generic and can scale up to the
enterprise level
so
the last example i
probably wouldn't spend too much time on
but just quickly walk through the
the main conclusion is that
oftentimes when you are building a
machine learning model or actually
building building any system
so to track
your different configuration and
experimentation is a tedious task so
sometimes you may have a machine
learning model that you happen to train
well and get very good results and a few
days later certain data input changes
certain configuration change it can no
longer regenerate that
that good results this is often
a very common problem in ml ops
so here we're going to illustrate
how julius can help solve this
like a tedious ml ops problem
uh
by taking advantage the uh the generic
capability of uh
reproduce and easily change the the
system
so
in order to fully persist a
distributed
enterprise system you have to do the
following three things so the entire
runtime environment including like a
hardware like
like os
of the library all of this has to be
has to be like
uh has to be
reproduced and then the input data has
to be persist and also entire code base
parameter and configuration of the
entire system has to be captured so the
first
item this is well
uh solved by using docker containers
that become a standard way of
having a standard environment hardware
os so that is well solved however the
input data
and the entire code base and
configuration still remain hugely
complex thing to capture especially for
we have a a system running on multiple
machines and spanning
a large number of components
so in this case like
uh
when we take advantage of the graph
computing platform in julius
uh we make the entire process super easy
this is pretty much the same code as
morrow showed in the distributed machine
learning
use case
and we can see that
once the user
finished the developer finished his
development and
get
reasonable results for example if he is
happy with this part of the results
what he can easily do is that
he can create another cluster
a fresh environment that has nothing to
do with the
environment the developer used for
for coding
and from this fresh
environment you can easily like
send the same commands senders same
rules and items to this fresh cluster
and turn on the recording
on the server side so once the server
side uh recording is is is complete
so you uh here you
uh
let's see show
so once the server side then
here we create a fresh cluster and we
turn on the recording on the server side
then you send the same command to this
new cluster which you want to reproduce
and then
we can take a a serialized
uh data structure of all the things that
happen on the server side that include
on your entire configuration environment
your
all the things you need to recreate that
distributed the graph then you can say
you can persist this record in aws or
some other storage and later on if you
want to recreate this environment you
can just replay this record and then you
can see that in the end you exactly
recreate the entire
distributed machine learning pipeline
with
with identical results so this is how
easy we can help
the
developers to manage their uh machine
learning experimentations so whenever
they have a good results you want to
persist it just take a few lines of code
to record it on an entirely new brand
new environment and
if you ever want to retrieve recover
that environment just replay it and it
becomes instantaneously available and to
be identical copy of your
your your previous configurations
so this is the last example i want to
share
um
so now let's
uh open it up for q a i'm going to
add
my colleagues to the screen and if you
have any
questions please feel free to ask
so let's see if there's any questions
coming through from
uh
from pigeonhole
uh so if there are no new questions
probably just go through some of the old
questions to make sure we have
adequately answered them
through the pigeonhole
yeah so there is a question about the
how can we catch the best model one of
them
are using
either for badge or streaming prediction
so we just showed that how easy it is to
take a record and replay that record
it works for both batch and streaming
mode
yeah there's a a question about um
what is the advantage of using a graph
based approach compared to convening
conventional one for machine learning
problem yeah so this all goes back to
the stellar advantage so if you
want scalability transparency
explainability lineage
low code
reproducibility and adaptability that
really
really you should look at the graph
based solution the conventional
programming language you have to solve
this problem
on your own
so
i think below there are some questions
with with no answers
yes there's a question about uh training
in python why did we train in python and
not in julia of course you can train in
julia
python example was to show the
interfacing capabilities and
of course python is widely used for
machine learning so that's why we chose
this language
in my case it was not distributed but a
smaller shown and you can also
distribute a machine learning training
process
yup so certainly you can use julia
version as well
[Music]
uh so there's a
question about
so
about pre-compilation overhead in graph
computing for the whole pipeline because
they're truly a pre-compilation
uh so yeah this is a this is a good
question so it's true that
we we do have this pre-compilation
overhead so the first time you run the
graph
calculation tend to be a bit slower
but the things is
graphic geared towards like heavy
combination that a little overhead for
precomputation is not not big deal
if you look at look at end-to-end
uh grand scheme of things
yeah there are a lot of questions we
probably can't answer uh live online we
try to
type in our answer
in the pigeonhole in the chat room
so
i don't know if there's more questions
coming through
uh yeah there's a new question what do
you see as your current biggest
challenges
in using or developing this
computational framework
right so that is actually a very good
question so i i would say maybe like
more millennials can share your thoughts
i would say that the graph computing is
a
a very new concept not too many
developers are familiar with it so i
would say probably require a bit like a
requirement
uh
learning and education to get to
get used to the way of thinking because
if you
thinking in the graph
construct in a graph manner it's a
different from thinking in terms of
traditional imperative function way of
programming
so i would say that
that changing
uh in your
uh your thinking about computation is
probably something we need to
need to work more on to get the
developer comfortable and see the
benefits of graph computing
yeah indeed i agree this is a difficulty
that may arise but
you can deal with it by training by by
seeing some examples uh especially this
this kind of tutorials are really
helpful for doing this
yeah there's a new question how to deal
with errors in certain node if they
occur after data upload or new execution
uh maybe new parameters yeah this is a
great question
so we didn't show this part of the
functionality but we support the generic
trigger so you can define a generic
trigger mechanism on your graph that can
monitor any of these
runtime exceptions or runtime conditions
so it can be data error or certain nodes
running too slow or data arrived
not in time so once you have the trigger
attached to your graph whenever this
condition happens you can define your
handler so that depending on how your
handler is written you can do different
things so for example you can ignore the
error you can page a developer or you
can try to roll the previous value
forward all of these different
strategies you can you can code in your
your
trigger handler so this is the virginal
way of handling errors or any kind of
runtime exceptions you may encounter
during the during the graph uh
computation it tends to be very
important for
running like a large production system
because you cannot
possibly like leave it to
to to human intervention every time this
condition occurs
uh so the next question is is there any
introductory
published books for graph computing with
julia
i'm not aware of anything
but yeah maybe that is a good suggestion
probably someone should write one
so it looks like there's more question
coming let's wait a few more
minutes
uh there will be a
presentation
from our ceo james lee in the main
conference
so uh certainly you're welcome to join
that presentation about the julius
technologies as well
okay so i think like uh um
probably we can conclude this work
workshop let me just at the end share
some of the
uh some of the links that will be useful
uh
for
for people to to find
relevant materials
just one
yeah i'm going to share my
my screen with a lot a couple last page
oh there's a new question okay let's
answer this new question
uh regarding persistence uh
that is
thanks for the comment
oh great yeah it's a it's on his comment
now the question i appreciate your nice
comment
so we're going to share a
a screen with a few links so that if you
want to find the
uh find the material afterwards
you can have the link in the video
right so here on the screen we're
showing the link to sign up for our
developer
uh
environment and also a few other
resources that
you've please feel free to browse and
also the second page is our like
blog pages and our email if you want to
reach out to us uh ask questions please
do so um using the email
or like leave a comment in our linkedin
pages
uh i think we can conclude this workshop
thank you very much for for joining
and look forward to hear from you
bye thank you very much bye thanks for
joining